قبل 50 عامًا، كان يظهر على التلفاز:
شخير الأب ليس مضحكًا، مهلاً،
ما الذي حدث، استيقظ واذهب إلى النوم،
لكن في الواقع، ليس
الشخير يمكن أن يكون مروعًا للغاية بالنسبة
لشريك السرير، وبالنسبة للعلاقة،
سيأتي إلي شخص ما  وأقول إن
شريكي في السرير هو الذي أرسلني إلى هنا
اليوم لأنني أزعج نومهم
إذا جاء إلي شخص ما وقام
بالشخير وقمنا بإجراء اختبار النوم على سبيل المثال
ونجد أنهم لا يعانون من انقطاع التنفس أثناء النوم
ما أفعله  عادةً ما نوصي في
هذه الحالة باتخاذ بعض
التدابير المحافظة، أحدها هو تلك الشرائط التي
رأيتها من قبل حيث تمر
فوق جسر الأنف. ما يفعلونه هو أنهم
يقرصون
الأنف بشكل متناقض هنا ولكن هذا يسمح في الواقع  هناك
المزيد من الهواء للدخول، وهناك أجهزة عن طريق الفم
مثل واقيات الفم التي
يمكن للناس الحصول عليها عندما يكون كل شيء جاهزًا ومصممًا، وهو
نوع من السحب السفلي
للأمام وما يفعله ذلك فهو يأخذ
اللسان بعيدًا عن الجزء الخلفي من الحلق
والذي يمكن أن يكون أيضًا أمرًا صعبًا للغاية.  فعال جدًا في علاج
الشخير، حيث أن جعل الشخص بعيدًا عن
ظهره عندما تكون على ظهرك،
يمكن للجاذبية أن تسحب كل
الأنسجة الرخوة إلى الجزء الخلفي من الحلق،
مما يزيد المشكلة سوءًا، في حين أن النوم على الجانب يمكن أن يكون
مفيدًا  تجنب الكحول سيجعل
الأنسجة أكثر استرخاء مرة أخرى مما يؤدي
إلى الشخير والتدخين خاصة قبل النوم،
فالدخان يهيج مجرى الهواء، لذلك إذا
كان لدى شخص ما مجرى هوائي ضيق وكان معرضًا
لخطر الشخير أو
انقطاع التنفس أثناء النوم، فإن التدخين سيجعل الأمر أسوأ في
الحالات الشديدة جدًا.  حيث لا يوجد شيء
يساعد في بعض الأحيان،
قد يضطر الشركاء إلى فصل السرير، حيث أن
القيام بهذه الأشياء يمكن أن يساعد عادةً إلى حد ما،
ولكن إذا كانت لا تزال
مشكلة كبيرة، فيجب عليهم زيارة
أخصائي النوم